learn a native cross-platform desktop
and mobile development with.net Maui
join senior software developer and
expert course creator Frank Leo as he
takes you on a fast-paced journey
through the fundamentalsof.net Maui in
this exciting course Frank will guide
you through the essentials of building
mobile applications with net Maui while
creating a contacts app you'll learn all
the key Concepts and techniques you need
to get started with this powerful
platform so whether you're a senior
developer looking to explore a new
technology or a newcomer to.net Maui
this course is the perfect jumping off
point for your journey welcome to this
course where are you going to learn
about.net Maui while creating a context
application in Dona 7. now let's take a
look at the mobile application that we
are going to create this is a context
application
we can add a contact enter the name
email phone number and so on we can also
delete the contact we can edit contact
update it and also we can search
contacts
and you can see that we actually have
field validation functionalities so this
is not just a crowd application what
is.net mode
and what is difference between Dane Maui
and darmin Forbes
so if we look at this dynamite
documentation from Microsoft you can see
that it's basically allows you to create
one code base but Target different type
of platforms so in most cases you don't
have to write different codes for
different platforms
you only need to write your code in one
place and that one place can be deployed
to different platforms you don't have to
make specific changes for the specific
Target platform
but isn't that the same as subwin forms
no it's not really the same
once you create the donai Maui project
you see in Visual Studio there's only
one project that one project allows you
to Target different platforms
whereas in xamarin forms okay so this is
the xamarin forms documentation from
Microsoft you can see that for different
platforms right this is for Android and
this is for iOS
researchers examples
you have different projects
right so there's there's going to be one
project for Android and then another
project for iOS and there could be other
projects for Windows phones uwps but
xamarin forms also has a shared code
base here right that is itself another
project
okay so when you create xamarin forms
application you will see different
projects right many projects one of them
is the most important one which is this
shared application code it contains all
of the logic and it forms but then you
will see also another project for
Android another project for iOS another
project for uwp another project for
Windows Phone for example so they're
kind of similar but very different right
practically very different so let's
actually take a look at the uh in the
major Studio how it looks like this is
uh xamarin forms Hollow World
application right you can see that it
contains many many projects right and
this the first one the portable one this
is the uh project that contains the
shared application code right most of
your logic most of your activities your
coding activities will go here right and
then you have different projects you
have to run them differently if you want
to Target Android you know you set this
one this project as the startup project
right and then you run the application
from here right if you want to Target
iOS then you have to set iOS project
that's the startup project and then you
start your project from there here's the
dynamoy application
you only actually
have one project and this one project
allows you to Target different platforms
so practically they're very very
different
okay so this is what I want to point out
in this video
and starting from next one we're going
to set up the visual studio environment
in order to allow us to create the
Dynamo application
in this video we're gonna try to go
through the steps of setting up the
environment in Visual Studio 2022 in
order to make your video Studio ready
for creating dynamoe applications right
so this is the video Studio installer
right you can find it in the search area
once you find it go to your video Studio
2022 right in my case I have the
Community Edition for 2022. once you
update to the latest click on the modify
button and then you will need to find
the desktop and mobile application part
right this part and it says.net
multi-platform application UI
development and you need to check it and
then you just need to install it right
in my case I have already done it and
once you've done it you will be able to
create a dynamite application
so once you updated your video Studio
2022 and then you install.net Molly now
you can create the project right so
let's go through the process creating a
new project
and then these are my recent project
templates but if you just installed
online Maui for the first time then you
wouldn't be able to see these so what
you can do is you can go to the search
bar and then you can type money
and then you'll be able to see a list of
applications we're going to select the
first one which is a.net Maui app right
and then click on the next one and we
are going to name the solution contacts
because we're going to create a contacts
application and I like to name the
solution after the purpose of the
application so in this case it's a
contacts app so I'm just going to call
it contacts and then the project I'm
going to have the purpose and then the
type of project in this case it's a Maui
app and then I'm going to click on the
next one
I'm going to select.net 7 I'm going to
click on create here you have it this is
the only project you see in this
solution right for now later we're going
to add different projects which mainly a
dynamoe class libraries to support us to
create applications in different layers
right we can't just put everything in
one project no companies does that so
you will have to learn to separate
different things in different layers
which will reside in different projects
different class libraries
so in this case uh what you can do is
first you can run it in Windows machine
right but in this course we're gonna
mainly Target Android but if you do
prefer to run it in Windows then you may
encounter kind of like a error like this
right so it says Windows Defender
Firewall blocked the broker.ex so you
will need to allow access right you need
to collect click on the allow access in
order to be able to deploy your
application to Windows environment very
likely it will prompt you to say that
you know you have to enable developer
mode for Windows right and then you just
click on the settings for developers
right you will see the screen and then
you just click on this button to turn on
the developer mode this will enable you
to deploy and run applications in
Windows mode that's how you set tap the
environment for Windows machine but what
I would try to do is to go to the
Android device manager
right and then you will need to add a
emulator in my case I'm using pixel 5.
by API 3031 you just need to install the
same thing you can you can use different
mobile phone emulators
but I chose this one and it's possible
that you will have to turn on hyper-v
right in order to accelerate the
emulator so that it runs faster
okay so this is the uh the options that
you need to choose when you go to
Windows features you turn on these
features in order to enable typer V to
accelerate your Android emulator
so once you're all done then you would
be able to
go to Android emulator and then you can
change this to Target you are selected
Android mobile emulator
right so in this case if we run the
application
it's going to take a while for the first
time and then it will be way faster
because after build it will identify the
differences between the this build and
next build and it will only deploy the
differences instead instead of the whole
thing right for the first time it's
going to compile and then it's going to
deploy everything into the uh the
emulator that's going to take a few
minutes depending on how fast your
machine runs
you know finally it deploys to the
application and next time it's going to
take shorter time but you can see that
the application is deployed to my pixel
5 emulator and then everything runs
you know normally and in the next video
we're gonna go inside the solution of
individual studio and see the project
structure
in this video let's take a look at the
project structure of a donut my
application okay so this is the
application that we just created when
you look at this application it seems
like my program.cs is the start point of
the application right and it does look
like it's trying to create an app but
let's think about this this application
can be deployed to different devices
different type of devices includes
Android iOS and whatnot
so how can this one program.cs be used
in different platforms they must have
their specific way to launch a
application right so this is not
actually the starting point the starting
point is in the platforms folder so if
you look at the Android folder you would
have a main application.cs and then you
can see that the main application.cs
actually uses the my program
so if we right click and go to
definition we can see that this goes
back to the Maui program.cis file and
this is the create Maui app static
method okay static function let's go
back and take a look at iOS right OS is
a different way to launch the app that's
a main app uh but then it uses the app
delegate and if you go into the app
delegate
a similar way of launching the program
is being used
right you can see that it also caused
the same static method
of course if you go into other devices
where this one would be similar to iOS
it uses the app delegate and then when
you go to app delegate it uses the
method right you can see that every
single platform points to this my
program.cs so our work
mostly are not in here okay so we can
just uh kind of ignore this for now
right so if you have any uh specific
platform code that you want to write
then you can go over here but in
Dynamite you don't usually encounter
that situation very often so most of
your code starting up code will be here
and mainly about dependency injection
which we'll cover later
practically everything would be starting
from here right we don't have to worry
about the platforms further practically
everything starts from this static
method which will be invoked from
different platforms
right it starts from here and then you
can see that it's trying to create a
application I've done in my application
right so we can go to this app this is
the next place where we need to look at
right so this app from the front end
which is the demo and it doesn't have
much it has a bunch of resources we
don't have to focus on but let's go back
we can see that it has a main page right
every single dynamoy application has a
main page and and it's just similar to
xamarin forms it has a main page but we
have a special type of main page
which is called appshop so for donating
a shell application is created by
default right which uses this shell page
you don't have to do it this way
but this is provided to you as a default
option which I I actually like it very
much the shell becomes the main page and
when you go to the Shell you can see it
has the shell content
right and then when you go go to the
back end and there's nothing on it so
the show itself is a opinionated way for
organizing all of your pages
in this case it points to the main page
route to the main page which is just
just a page you don't have to call it
main page it's just a page
one thing may be confusing and you have
to understand that this main page
is just referring to this one main page
right this main page and then if you go
to the code behind you can see that this
main page is a Content page right the
type is content page
whereas if you go to the app go behind
here this main page is the applications
main page
right it's a member of the application
and the type of that is a page
they are completely different object
objects
they are completely different objects
so don't get confused this main page is
not referring to this main page
so we have IOS
we have Android and we have Windows for
example
and of course we can have more but
everything actually goes into this my
program.cs
we don't have to even worry about the
the different platforms but kind of
ignore this layer what really matters is
that our Codes start from Maui
program.cs
and then this goes to app this app
represents our application and every
application needs to have a main page
and in donat Maui the default main page
is the shell page which is the app shell
you don't have to do it this way but
this is the default
structure that is provided what's this
app shell
it organizes all of the other Pages for
example we may have page one page two
page three page four and no matter what
type of hierarchy you actually have
let's for example page one has
two child Pages like two children and
page two and page one are on the same
level each single one of these pages
will need to register
to app Shell at least for routing
purpose so this is the project structure
of the.net Maui application that is
provided out of the box
again app shell and the way that it
organizes the pages is a opinionated way
for organizing the application and all
of the pages you don't have to do it
this way you can create your own page
and make that page as the main page but
in this course we are going to utilize
the different functionalities that is
provided by a shell page so let's look
at the documentation from Microsoft
right a shell page provides four
different features right fundamental
features but for me
and mainly focus on this one
right because the other three different
features there are kind of implemented
through this fly out and tabs
right this this is the fly out and then
you have different tabs and then you
have your search bar here if you don't
like this kind of UI structure you can
still use shop application for at least
registering different routes for
different pages and then navigate to
those pages with the URL based
navigation scheme which we'll cover
later okay so this is everything for
this video the project structure of
a.net my application
I'll see you in the next one
application is a stateful application
that has a user interface what is a
stateful application it just means that
it needs to maintain a state in a state
it just represents the data right it's
just the data so in this type of
application we have three basic elements
that all developers need to deal with
while we are creating the application so
of course the first one is the state
which is the data and then the view
which represents the user interface the
state will need to be displayed in The
View let's put a user here and then user
will then interact with the view and
then that generates the events and then
developers will handle the event
which will in turn change the state and
then this cycle goes on which means when
the data is changed the view gets
updated again
and then the user plays with the user
interface and triggers the event and
then the state is updated again
so Seiko goes on and on okay let's take
a look at the application ourselves and
see where are these three different
elements in the main page so this is the
main page we can see that we have this
data here right which is the state and
then the state is not initially
displayed on the user interface where's
the user interface it's represented by
the xaml file so this is the xaml file
we have this initial state that is not
actually displayed here it just says
click me
right once the user clicks on the button
which triggers the event then the events
is handled by this uncounter clicked
event handler
then the state is changed and the state
is manually assigned to the text
property of the button so that displays
the state on the user interface and
completes the cycle right and the user
can choose to interact with the user
interface which means that the user can
click on the button again and then this
whole cycle goes on and on
but this particular way of handling the
events is called event driven
development
whereas in dollar Maui we have another
way which is mvvm
these two different ways handles all
three different aspects of a development
cycle right the state The View and the
event handling in this particular case
the event driven mode each event will
have an event handler in the code behind
of the user interface okay so this is
the code behind and this is the user
interface file right the event handlers
are all in here and then we just make
the logic Happening Here in the manually
update the user interface
mvvm will be covered later which is more
organized but I just want to cover all
these three different elements today so
that we have a a map for our learning
process
in the previous video we talked about
the download Maui application has three
Essential Elements and in this video
let's focus our attention on The View
which is the UI element so a dynami
application may have different pages in
this video let's focus our rotation on a
page right what is really on a page so
let's take a look at this main page
we have the Zumo bio and azamo.cs file
the demo file represents the UI and the
zamod.cs file is the code behind which
provides logic and feeds data to be
presented in the UI focus our attention
on the UI part we can see that it's a
page it's a Content page right
essentially it's just a page
so what is a page
application may have different pages
it's basically just referring to that
area that occupies the whole user
interface so this is a page and then
inside the page there could be different
UI elements like buttons images list
views and whatnot
so if we put them in a diagram to
express this more clearly we have a page
right and then the inside page we may
have different UI elements
under other development Frameworks like
web development Frameworks
we call this UI elements controls
right but inside.net Maui we call this
UI elements views this view is different
from what we mentioned last time
this View and last time the diagram is a
generic term that refers to UI
here these elements are called views
each one of them is a view this is
specific to the night Maui therefore in
Donna Maui we have a page and inside the
page we can have one or more views
however if you put these views directly
under a page you will get a error right
for example we come over here we look at
our main page we can see we have image
we have labels right we have buttons
these views the each one of them is a
view is actually under a layout well
this scroll view is also a layout the
layout is directly under a page so
therefore we cannot put multiple view
views under a page we have to put them
under a layout and then put that layout
under a page in this case it's scroll
View and then inside the scroll view it
has another layout right it doesn't have
to have another layout but in this case
it has another layout so you have to
remember that directly under a page
there can be only one layout under that
layout there can be more layouts views
in fact a layout itself is also a view
so let's actually go to the definition
of this vertical stack layout you can
see that it's derived from
stack paste and then stack base direct
from layout and if you go to layout
it's actually derived from View
right and if you go to uh for example
the image we go to the definition
you can see it is derived from The View
so a layout is actually a view you can't
see the layout but it's used for
organizing the individual views group
them together provide layout to them so
therefore which you really have is
inside a page there is a layout right so
this is a layout and then inside the
layout you can have multiple views and
also remember that a layout is also a
view so therefore inside a layout you
can have multiple layout and then inside
those layout you can have multiple
views so the structure is therefore like
this
you have a page one page
right and then
a page can have single layout
right and then inside the layout you can
have multiple views
if we remove this layout
okay let's try to remove this layout
you can actually see compile time error
here is that the property content is not
set more than it's set more than once
right so what we are we're trying to
play the elements inside a Content page
which is actually trying to set the
content property
but it's complaining that it's set more
than once that means that actually
inside a Content like inside the page
the content element can only contain one
View
right this is what it's trying to
complain so therefore you can only put a
layout here
you don't have to have the scroll view
any layout will do so if we delayed the
scroll View
it still works right at least it doesn't
complain anymore uh but in this case
it's just it just want to let it scroll
as well
that's why it added a scroll view so
that's the first concept I want you to
remember right which is this a page
contains layout and then layout contain
views
the second concept I want you to know is
the namespaces okay so we have these
namespaces what what does it what does
it mean you can see these are
xmos right XML elements but why scroll
view is uh recognized but if I put
scroll view one then it's not right so
automatically the the closing element
becomes scroll view one but it's
complaining that scroll V1 was not found
so these namespaces
um
are provided here it's exactly like the
namespaces that are provided in C sharp
right so for example
namespace.net
if we don't have namespaces even
um so so let's delete this
you can see even the button doesn't even
recognize right so we put namespaces so
that we provide definition for our uh
keyword that we use inside a programming
language right so in xamo it's a it's
another programming programming language
that is created for Donna Maui
right but where does these keywords uh
where do these keywords come from they
come from namespaces in this particular
case it it came from the Steve file
namespace right that's XML namespace
which is uh microsoft.nemon
and then you have uh extension
right so for example if you want want to
give it a name
uh you can say x dot name and then you
can say image one right so you give it a
name but the name itself it doesn't come
from the default namespace this is
default namespace you see if I remove X
then the name is not actually recognized
right that means that this name property
doesn't come from the default namespace
it comes from uh this Microsoft zamo
namespace so therefore if you want to
give it a name you have to use x dot X
call it sorry and then if you want to
refer to anything that is within the
main page uh for example this uh button
click event
which you can actually go to definition
and then that immediately jumped over to
encounter clicked so it knows this
encounter clicked method in the code
behind just because we're referencing
the class
if we remove this we will see that if we
right click here and then go to
definition it doesn't know where to go
right and so if we put it back
now if we go down and try to do the same
thing we go to definition it will be
able to jump over to the code behind so
that's namespace and it's a very
important concept that you would want to
know because later when you code you
thought that this is going to work but
it's not being recognized that's just
because you may need to add some
namespaces okay that's everything I want
to cover in this video I'll see you in
the next one
in this video let's talk about URL based
navigation
we are going to have three pages in this
context application right we're going to
have a main context page that is going
to show a list of contacts and then
we'll be able to navigate to edit
contact page where we can edit page or
even just view the contact details and
then navigate back right and then we
have another page add contact page
where we navigate to add a new contact
and then navigate back so let's jump
into video studio and create these three
pages so that I can demonstrate you how
to do how to do the URL based navigation
we can just start with adding these
three different empty pages
so let's go to create a folder let's
call it views right and then
we are going to have
to add a new atom and here we're just
type in page then you can see contact
page let's select the xaml page c-sharp
H that means that you are not going to
have a zamo representation as a friend
front end everything has to be added a
c-sharp class
so I would personally prefer to use
symbol so that the front end and the
back end are nicely separated right
decoupled so let's select this and let's
call it contacts
page
so this is the main page and then you
can see that it has a title here
and let's just delete the page and then
we're going to add another one
so we can add another one we can call it
added compact page
and then here we can just add a space
and a delete page again
and then last but not least we're gonna
add another one and this is going to be
called add
contact page
and again we're going to add a space
here and then delete the page
now we have these three different pages
but if we run the application we're now
going to see these three different pages
so let's
um start running it so just hit F5 right
to run the application in the back mode
run the application on debug mode
um it triggers the hot reload for data
Maui so that any changes you make in the
xaml file will be reloaded and
redisplayed in the application
immediately you can see the application
runs but no matter where I go
right uh
like it doesn't show those three
different pages
so before we implement the URL based on
navigation let's try the how to reload
so let's go to the main page because
this is actually just displaying the
main page right and if we change
anything for example
we change uh hello world to hello.net
Maui
and then if we save it and come back
over here
you can see that immediately the change
is reflected let's stop debugging
because we are going to make some call
behind changes the code behind changes
will not be reflected immediately so it
needs a recompower and redeployment
oh
so let's go to the app shell
like we mentioned before the shell
provides URL based navigation and inside
the Constructor is a perfect place for
us to register the routes in order to
jump to any pages with URL base
navigation we first need to let the
system know that we have these routes
that points to these pages so one of the
way to do it is to say rotting
right there is this routing and then uh
we can say register route
and then here you can see that the first
parameter is a string
and that represents the key of the route
or the name of the route but it has to
be unique
right for that we can say name of
the class name so name of the contacts
page right so context page we can do a
control Dot to import the namespace and
then here we need to provide the type
okay so let's go to the second signature
so the second parameter is the type
we can use type of context page
so basically now the inside.nymali
the system it has a key and value pair
so the name of the page is the key
it doesn't have to be the name of the
page you can call it anything but it's
easier if we just use name of the uh the
page right because that's usually unique
and then the type
so later when you navigate to this page
it knows the type of the page and then
it will be able to construct dynamically
on demand
in the memory and then show you the page
that's just because it knows the key
value pair it knows which type to
instantiate
right so we have another two
routes so we're going to register the
other two routes the name of edit
contact page
and then
last one is I'm going to have name off
and then add contact page and then they
suggest me to to have
the rest so I don't have to type
everything
okay now I register these three
different routes
right so let's demonstrate how we can
navigate to these three different first
of all
I don't want the main page to be the
home page I want the context page to be
the
the main page to do that we can go to
the friend hand
of that the show right here it
registered the route in a different way
so now I can say contacts
page and then here it has this local
and then you can see that this logo is a
namespace right extended namespace
where I can say local and then I can see
uh what's defined under that namespace
but our context page is not under the
local namespace
our namespace the context page
is under contacts.my.views
views so for that we can say
views equals
CLR
namespace right and then here we're
going to say contacts dot my
dot views so it shows this directly here
right
so now we can use views
to provide
the type information
right views colon then you can see those
three different pages that we added
earlier so we're going to use context
page so basically this is the same thing
as rotting.register route
this route is the key provides the name
if we navigate to definition
you can see this is a string
right for the shell content
and then here
is the type of that so we provide a name
and we provide the type
now if we run application we will be
able to see the context page but there's
nothing on it
what we can do is we are going to add
two buttons
just for demonstration purpose later
we're going to remove it
so here there's a label already but
we're going to add a button
and then the button text is to say go to
just call it at or added contact and
then we are going to have another button
and we're going to call it at contact
and when we click on the added contact
we want to go to edit contact page for
that we will need to have an event
handler to handle the click event
to distinguish between this button and
this button
we will need to provide a name first
like I mentioned last time you you need
to use the X X extension
to give it a name
because the name property is not in the
default namespace
so here
I can call it BTN add it
contact
right
and then here I can call it BTN at
contact now if I go to clicked I can tap
to edit event handler and that will have
our name in it right and this what it
does is that is not only just created
this uh it just assigned this string to
this property but also create it a event
handler in the code behind it's empty of
course for now
in here we're going to say new event
handler instead of selecting existing
one we're going to say new event handler
and then now it has
our name in it and then created another
event handler here like I mentioned
before we are going to create this a
context application twice the first time
we're going to create it with event
driven development the second time we're
going to use mvvm pattern
the event driven development is easier
to to learn
so it gives us a lot of opportunity to
understand Maui and then we're going to
move on to mbvm which is usually used in
different companies for mobile
development
so that's why we have these two
different ways of creating the same
application so let's continue
here we're going to demonstrate how to
do the URL based navigation we are going
to say show dot current right so this is
the current shell
which is
let's go to definition
you can see that this current shell is a
static member of the shell class
right
but it refers to the Shell that we have
in here right so therefore it knows all
of the registered routes so we are going
to say go to async
right
and where are we going to go
so here you can see that the first
parameter is shell navigation state but
but it's really just the string but it's
not any string it is the key of a
particular route so we can just say uh
name off okay add it contact page then
it's very simple it's just that we are
navigating
to this added page and then we can do
the same thing here you can say shell
right current we find the current shell
and then
that current shell knows our registered
out so we need to provide a key here in
this case it's contact page
and that's it
let's see whether it works or not
okay now we can see that the page is
displayed right instead of the original
main page we're displaying the contacts
page
right we can see that two buttons are
connected to each other so we will need
to fix that first so let's go to the
context zamo and then this is vertical
stack layout what it means is that all
of the views inside the layout will be
vertically stacked on top of each other
right but it has a spacing
it has a spacing property here so let's
put five here right it's a unit it's not
pixels or anything it's just a special
unit
um and then let's go here you can see
that it's nicely separated now
now we can click on the edit contact
button
you can see that it navigated to the add
contact page right and if we click on
the back button it will navigate back
and then we go to add contact
you can see it it went to the uh at
conic page click on the back arrow it
goes back another thing we can do is for
practice purpose we can add another
button here and we can give it a name
and we can call it vtn cancel right and
the text is cancel this will take us
back to the contacts page so we don't
have to use the back arrow we are going
to add a clicked event handler
right and then I'm going to do the same
thing on the edit page I'm gonna add a
button I'm gonna give it a name
I'm going to call it BTN edit com uh
sorry ptn cancel
and then we are going to create a text
and call it cancel
and now we're going to create the event
handler
you can see that it automatically knows
that this has to be rebuilt so actually
let's stop debugging then create the
event handler
right
and now
we can go to the call behind here and
then here
we can do it a little bit differently we
can do shell current
and then go to async this is the same
but here we can use dot dot so dot dot
you know in photo structure dot dot
means the parent
so can you start.t here to say that
we're going to navigate back to the
parent page okay which is the context
page
so we can use that you can copy this and
go to
over here
and and we can say shocker and go to
async.au it's the same thing now let's
run the application
so let's go to edit contact
right we can see we are on add a contact
page click on cancel this takes us back
to contacts go to add contact
click on cancel also takes us back to
contacts
right another thing that I want to point
out is that if you want to use the
actual name instead of the dot to go to
the contacts page
you can't just use the name of
contacts page
why is that that's because uh if we go
to the Shell page you can see that
uh
the contacts page is the first page
which is basically the main page
right for main page shell navigation
when you use URL based navigation you
have to provide the absolute path right
so the way that we are navigating
uh in context page here we are just
using relative path
right the absolute pass it starts with
slash slash
so let's go to the documentation you can
see that
this is the documentation of shell
navigation
right you can see that
the first level is
the root right and it starts with slash
slash
so
if you want to go to the the main page
you have to specify the slash slash so
let's go here right if you do this it's
not going to work so how it's going to
work you can use string interpolation
here so we're going to say slash slash
and then curly braces
so this provides the absolute pass and
this is going to work
okay so let's run the application
and then let's go to add contact
right so now we are on the add contact
page right here and then clicking on the
cancel button this will take us back to
the contacts page so again to navigate
back to the main page you have to
provide the absolute pass or you can use
dot dot that's everything for this video
I'll see you in the next one
we are going to start creating a contact
list on the context page and what we are
going to use is list view so in this
video Let's Start Learning the basics of
using list View
so a few videos ago I mentioned that
there can be only one view on the top
level inside a page so in this case you
can see that on the top level is the
vertical stack layout and everything is
inside it
we don't need the buttons we don't need
the labels we will talk about the layout
later
today we are going to use list view so
we can say list review
and if we run it you can see that
there's there's nothing on the screen
but listview has background
so turn on the background like we give
the background some color for example
Quran color it goes blue we can see that
everything become blue right that means
that list view occupies the whole page
you need to know that list view is it's
not like there's when there's nothing in
the list it's not occupying the whole
screen I need to know that it always
occupies the whole screen
uh and uh I'd like to give it a
transparent background because in
different devices for example another
device is a different type of operating
systems like Android or iOS the
backgrounds color sometimes um is
slightly different so to make it
consistent just make it transparent
also that you need to know that list
View
it automatically has the the scroll
functionality
so later when you know that there's some
such a thing that called scroll view
okay so you can actually see a scroll
view is a layout
scroll View
is a type of layout of course
there can be only one root view in here
so scroll view a list view of the kind
of uh
conflicting with each other you can only
have one top level so if you put less
view inside a scroll wheel is going to
work but but it doesn't make sense
because list view itself already has the
functionality of a scrolling uh if you
add another scroll scrolling
functionality on top of it it's going to
affect each other so when you have a
list view don't add scroll view if you
go to definition
a scroll view is a type of layout right
so we don't need scroll view I just want
to mention that when you have a list
View
don't add scroll View
okay
so we have a scroll view but there's
nothing in it the first thing we need to
do is to make scroll view display
something so when we come to the code
behind we can see that we still have the
event handlers but we don't have the
buttons anymore so we can delete the
event handlers
so now in order to show something in the
list View right we need to have an array
of something to display right so let's
say we have a list of a list of strings
and this strings we call it let's say
contacts right and then we are going to
have
this and
what's going to be inside it is just a
list of
and let's say there's
Zhang and dough and so we have these
names
and then we will need to provide this
data to the list
so how do we do that we need to first of
all have a name so that at the core
behind we can have a reference reference
the list View
so we have list contacts
and then
we can say item source
item Source the type of item source is I
enumerable
so we can put contacts over here
and now let's run the application and
see whether there are any changes now
you can see that we have these contacts
nicely displayed in the list View
so this is a very very basic data
binding when I display this list view in
here you can see there's separators
rather separators and if you click on it
right basically when an item is selected
there's a default color highlighting
which item you selected so if we go over
here
and let's format it nicely different
properties in here more attributes and
then there's a there's a separator right
they're separated color
uh they're separator visibility if you
don't like it you can turn it off okay
if you want to change the color for
example I want to change it to let's say
agua
just for demonstration purpose I don't
like the the color but you see the color
has changed right and if you don't like
the separator at all then you can use
visibility you can set it to none and
then coming over here you can see that
there's no separator anymore I do like
the default one which is showing the
separator but maybe we can change it to
Silver
all right change it to Silver and then
uh the color becomes simmer which is
very similar to the default the next
thing I want to show you is to actually
bind it to a class right we can't always
have data in in a stream because
contacts has like names phone numbers uh
maybe emails maybe addresses so it's
better to use a class to do that so
let's stop debugging and let's create a
contact class over here uh later we're
gonna separate that kind of class in the
different class Library which is the
correct way to do things when you go to
a company you will never see people have
the class defined in in the same file
right there are two different classes in
the different seminal sometimes it
happens but most most of the time you
have your core objects right so core
classes the business core classes in a
different class Library which we're
going to do later we're going to follow
the clean architecture or the clean code
approach right for now for demonstration
purpose I'm going to have a class over
here which is going to be called Contact
right and then we are going to have just
some simple properties for example maybe
you will have a name maybe maybe email
instead of a list of strings
we are going to have a list of contacts
list of
contact over here
change to contact
and then we're going to initialize uh
this contact
so I have a list of contacts and now I
don't have to change this and let's
let's run it and see what's going to
happen
okay so let's speed it and run it again
all right so we have something displayed
but this time unfortunately these people
are not being displayed but class names
are being displayed right the class
names along with namespaces being
displayed why is that
so the default behavior of assigning a
list to the item source is that the list
view will take each one of these
object
and run at two strings when you run a
two string
whatever it gets
it will be displayed right so for
example if I set a breakpoint over here
right and then I'm gonna stop it and run
it again and let's trigger the
breakpoint and you will see what I mean
okay so we have this contacts
so let's actually do a quick watch
and then if I do like take the first one
which is zero in the index we can see
that we have
the first one which is strong though
and then if I do a two string
let's see what is the value you can see
that the value is exactly the one that
is being displayed in that list right
so this is what I mean
when you just
bind when you just assign the context
to the item Source it's going to take
each one of those contacts and run a two
string it's going to just display that
the result of two string inside the list
so in this case it's just the namespace
plus the class name so that's not really
what we want
right of course to fix this problem you
can come over here and override the two
string method so that you can display
whatever you want
but that's not really the proper way to
do it in Dynamic mode
a correct way to do it is to use data
binding which means that
we assign this the item source that is
actually okay
well we need to tell the list view what
to display and how to display it and the
way to do that is to go to the front end
in the demo file
and then over here
we need to give it a template right so
because we are trying to tell a list
view exactly how to display the item
so we need to specify that in in the
template and we can use we can say less
view dot item template
okay this item template because each
item in the list is an item right that's
why it's called item template and then
we have data template
so the data template is basically just
just the item template
and inside it we can have a different
type of cells we can have view cell
which is the most flexible approach uh
there's uh there's this image cell right
and there's the basic one is taxa so we
can try to use textile for now the tax
of that is the one that I want to show
for now so what is the tax of that we
can see binding
finding
and name
all right so basically with the curly
braces we are just saying that we are
targeting a object right so if you have
worked with JavaScript before a credit
brace refers to a object
so what is the object we are referring
to it is the one that is is being bound
to the item so what is being bound to
the item
you can see that we have context as the
item source so of course each item is a
one of these contact
right so this
without specifying The Source by default
it refers to the contact object right
which is bound to the item to the item
we're specifying an item template of
course this is referring to the object
that is bound to the item which is a
contact
so that's why
in here this binding just means that we
are referring to the object that is
being bound to the item and then here
we're just saying what is the pass we
can say pass equals to the property of
that object
which is name
all right we can see that you won't get
any intelligence over here it doesn't
really know it's just a string right
this this is just a string so it doesn't
really know but uh you you just have to
type it directly
so so here the path is a default
property of The Binding class and
you can just put name directly over here
because of the default property so you
can omit the pass
so you can put name of here it just
tells that name Maui that we are trying
to display the name property of the
contact class right the context object
so what's this change if we run the
application
[Music]
now you can see
that the names are being displayed again
right another property of the text cell
is called detail
so I'm going to show you what it is now
this detail is also a string but again
you can use binding
okay so we're binding to the property
another property of the context class
and of course the only other property we
have is the email so we can use email
now let's see what it looks like let me
come over here you can see that we have
the names and then the detail at the
bottom the names are highlighted it's
pretty nice
but if you think that everything is kind
of squeezed together so it can change
the the height of the Rope right or to
hide them the item but it's called row
height
okay so for example if we say 100
and then let's take a look at what it
looks like each one of those pretty tall
so maybe change that to 80.
and that looks much better uh it's still
too much
maybe 70
yeah 70 looks much better
say let's say 65.
so now it looks much better so these are
all the things I want to cover for today
we basically cover some basics of list
view right how to data bind to it how to
adjust the appearance and in the next
few videos we are going to use list view
for our Connex application I'll see you
in the next one
do you still remember this map that we
mentioned a few videos ago
so in the previous video when we cover
the basics of list view we covered the
view which is the UI and the state which
is the data and also how we map the
state to the view right which is a basic
data binding that we covered in the
previous video in this video we are
going to cover basic events for list of
view so that we can actually do
something with studies let's come to our
solution and let's go to the context
page when you have a phone and has a
list you really use a finger to tap on
item of a list
so there are a couple of events that we
are interested in
one of them is called item selected
so let's actually try to handle that
event and see what happens okay so this
generated a new event handler
which automatically showed up here let's
actually set up breakpoint and run our
applicant see whether it's triggered or
not
okay so I'm going to run the application
okay so I'm going to click on one of the
item and you can see that it's triggered
this breakpoint
right so let's continue and
if I click on the next item
it trigger the breakpoint again so we're
going to continue but this time we're
going to click on the same item
so I clicked on it so I'm going to click
down a few times
you can see that this breakpoint is not
being triggered
so what does that mean
it means that this event handler item
selected is only triggered when item
selection has changed right at the
beginning there's nothing selected so
you click if you click on any item the
selection changed from nothing
to one of the item right the item that
you clicked on and then when you click
on something else another item
then of course it's going to trigger the
event
but if you click on the same item
it's not going to trigger the event
right so if you are going to use this
event handler to do things then you have
to face this problem so there are a
couple of ways to fix this problem
one of the ways is to deselect the
selected item right inside this event we
can just use
list
contact
dot selected item so we can set it to
now so basically you do your logic here
right your own logic and then at the end
you can deselect it
okay so let's run the application again
and to see the behavior so now if I
click on item but you can see that
the event is triggered right and if I
run the application again
you now notice that the item is not
being selected right because we
deselected it again so this event is
going to happen over and over again just
because we deselected the item one thing
we can use to test the application to is
to use the built-in display alert right
so we can display a message
so this is going to be for example test
and then the message is
test and cancel is let's just say okay
right and we run the application again
now we don't have the breakpoint
but we have
a message
you can see the message and we click on
the OK button the message disappears
and I can click on the same
item and Trigger
the alert let's take a look at another
event let's go to the demo file and
another one is called item
tapped right so let's create a new event
handler and then let's go to the code
behind again
you can see a new event handler is
generated so again let's set some
breakpoint
and then let's run the application again
to see the behavior to see whether there
are any differences between the two okay
so the application runs and we click on
the item
you can see the first event is triggered
is the item selected and then if we
continue then the second event is
triggered again right so this item tab
is triggered afterwards
one of the more reliable way to just
select item is to actually do the
deflection inside here inside the tapped
event
I'm going to do it here
and then
you handle your logic inside item
selected why is that
why is that it's because this item tab
event is always happening right whether
you're selecting an item or not
selecting an item whether you tap on the
same items or type on a different item
right therefore
the this event is triggered way more
times than the item selected event right
so to handle your logic you don't want
to put your logic inside here if user
use their fingers to tap on the item
like very very quickly this event
handler is going to be triggered many
many times right where this one is
triggered less so therefore we want to
do our deselection here and we want to
do upper logic here
because you don't want your logic to run
inside here because it's going to run
for many many times right so this is a
more reliable way to put our deselection
over here and putting our logic inside
item selected is better
so to give it a test make sure that it
actually works we can whatever display
alert inside here okay so we're gonna do
test and then I'm gonna say okay and
we're going to run the application again
so when I click on an item
and
we see this alert click on OK click on
another one
we see the alert
and you can see that that this selection
is happening right nothing is being
selected so this is the exact Behavior
we are expecting
here you will notice there is actually a
bug I think it's a bug for item
selection right for this item selected
event this event is going to be
triggered twice if we use we try to
deselect right so let's take a look at
the behavior I click on this
and then we have actually let's disable
let's remove the breakpoint
so I click on that already and then now
I click on the OK button
but you see that I clicked um
the okay button already but this alert
dialog is not disappearing I'll have to
click on the OK button again
right so it appears that I click on the
same button again but it's not the case
it's actually what uh what's actually
happening is that this event handler is
triggered twice so let's put the
breakpoint back again
okay and then let's click on any of the
item
and run it again
and you see that it happens twice
right so now there's actually two
dialogues that's why we need to click on
twice
um I think the logic here is that this
is this shouldn't be called item
selected it should be called unchanged
right item selection changed what is
happening is that first time you click
on the item
the selection the item selected changed
from now
to something
and then because we deselected here
so the item selected is changed from
something
to know
and that triggers the event again
right so I think it's a bug but we
always have a workaround to solve this
problem we can just
say if list contacts
dot selected is not now
and and then we put our logic inside
here right so our logic should be inside
here we only deal with anything if there
is actually a selected item
right if there's no select item we don't
need to do anything
so if we run the application again now
you should see that the alert only
triggered once
so let's run application okay so let's
try that click on this
we have this alert click on OK button it
disappears right away right so upper
work round works
so now let's actually put our logic here
so what do we want to do we want to when
we click on a contact we want to go to
that contact
right so
uh which means that we want to go to the
added contact page
so for that if you remember our logic is
to use shell dot current dot go to async
we can directly call it this way or we
can use our weight
and async and then we can go to the page
so for that
we're going to say added contact page
and then later probably in the next
video we're going to talk about how to
pass information when we navigate to
another page today we're just going to
navigate to the page because we mainly
want to focus on the event handling of
the list view okay so let's click on any
of the item
and we're looking at the added contact
page now cancel button going back click
on it again I'm going to add a contact
page okay
so that's everything I want to cover in
this video I'll see you in the next one
we already have a contacts page the next
step is to create an added contact page
to be able to see the details of the
contact and be able to add it to contact
before we do anything if we look at the
context page we can see that we have the
hard-coded list here
right and then we have the contact class
the core class that is defined right on
this page uh the code behind of the page
so that's something we have to fix
before we can continue
so I know that I've mentioned eventually
we're going to have a clean architecture
but for now for the purpose of learning
we are not going into
the proper architecture right now we are
going to create a folder right in the
same project and we're going to call it
models
so we are going to have our contact
class defined
inside the models folder okay so I'm
gonna cut this piece of code here and
then I'm going to create a contact class
here inside the models folder
is going to call it contact
all right so this is going to be a
public class
and then actually I'm just going to
replace this with this and
to Define this class properly at least
we're going to add another property is
there's going to be more properties
later but for now we're going to have a
contact ID
right so
when that is done when we come back to
our contacts page we can still see we
have this list color coded here how do
we deal with this
now let's look at this width this is
data right so I know that we are hard
coding that data but whether we're
dealing with the in-memory to the
storage or we're dealing with a file to
store the data and then later we'll
retrieve the data from the file or we're
dealing with a database and we retrieve
the data from database into our
application we need to have a central
place to encapsulate data operations
meaning insert data update data retrieve
data and delete data okay we need to
have a central place to encapsulate
those upper operations we can't let
those Logics scattered in our
application everywhere for that we can
use repository right a repository is a
central place where those operations are
encapsulated right a shield of
replication from doing those operations
so that when we replace the repository
with another one then we can do with
data from different sources right we can
never repository for a memory we can
have a repository for file and we can
have a repository for database
right for in memories databases are
pretty good for quality assurance right
to fake some data
from files we don't use that often from
database is very good for enterprise
level development for now we're going to
have a simple static repository and
later we're going to create proper
repositories and then we use dependency
injection to inject the repository into
our replication
and to do that we're just going to
create a repository class enter enter
the models folder and we are just going
to call it compact
Repository
and this is going to be a static class
this is a repository which serves the
purpose of doing all of those data
operations within the memory
right of course later when we use clean
architecture we are going to have
different repositories to deal with
databases for example and then we we're
going to use dependency injection to
inject those repositories into our
application logic layer but for now we
are going to only have this
to deal with in memory now it's going to
be a static class and then we are going
to have a static list
okay so let's go back and just uh
basically I'm just going to cut this
part
and then we're going to replace this
so we initialize this data with four
contacts so that at least we have
something to see before we add a contact
right so we have this and of course we
need to have a method for get all of the
contacts so we are going to have a list
of contact
right and then we can have get contacts
and this is just going to give us all of
the contacts and this has to be a static
method perhaps we are going to add
another one
okay and this is one single contact so
we're going to say can't get contact by
ID
right and then we're gonna put in
contact ID
and then we are going to say return
Dash contacts um
should use Dash
well it doesn't matter we don't have to
use stash but I'm choosing to use stats
in dash in this course I mean not Dash
underscore so any score contacts
underscore
contacts
and then over here I'm just going to say
first or default we use Lambda
expression and contact ID equals to
contact ID here this contact is from
within this namespace which is this
particular contact
right so so now we have get contacts we
have get contact by ID and I think those
methods are good enough for now let's go
back to our class here we have the
contacts
so we are just going to use our contact
Repository
inside this class and then we're going
to say get contacts
and if we run the application again we
should have everything that we have seen
before now you can see that it complains
about the contact inside the contact
context page it says contact is a Amigos
reference between
our own contact and there is actually a
contact inside the communication name
space
so in order to refer to our contact
we're going to use something like this
I'm going to say using
contact equals contacts dot my DOT
models dot contact so this right tells
our code that when we refer to contact
inside this file we're referring to our
own contact instead of the contact under
the communication namespace
okay so let's try to run the application
again now you can see that all of the
contacts are listed in the list view
that means our static repository is
working for us
so now we are ready to go to the next
step which is to create the edit contact
page currently we do have an added
connect page if we click on it we go to
the add iconic page but there's there's
nothing in it right we need to view the
video's information on the connect page
first of all right and then we can deal
with the update
uh to in order to see the iconic
information on the ad iconic page we
need to know which one we're looking at
right which contact we're looking at or
basically we're we're saying that we
need to know which contact the user
clicked on in the contact list page
right
so to know that we will need to pass
information from the contacts page
to the edit contact page and how do we
do that so if we look at our contacts
page when the user clicked on a contact
item we are using URL based navigation
to navigate to the added contact page
and if you have done any uh web
application development or if you just
go online you have seen those patterns
that uh in the URL we have a question
mark and then there's equal sign and
afterwards there's some strings after
that
um
so that is called a query stream right
so here because we have the URL based
navigation in Dynamite it actually
borrows the same concept so we can pass
those information from a page to another
page when we use URL based navigation in
Dynamite so let's see how we do that
here here we can pass different things
not only just streams but for Simplicity
we're going to learn with strings first
right so
um basically here we are just going to
say something like you know which page
are we going to right and then we can
use the question mark and say you know
contact ID equals to whatever and then
on the ideaconic page we can receive
this contact ID so in order to do that
we are going to let's roll back you can
see we're using name off but let's see
use a string interpolation here
right with Kerdi braces and then here we
can just say let's let's use ID so just
for Simplicity right ID and what is the
ID uh it's the selected item this list
contacts dot selected item and then this
selected item is a object but we can
cast that into
a contact object
right
so let's do that
once we cast it into contact object then
we can know the contact ID
so here this is the query string
parameter and this is the value
right we can receive that information
on this page which is the add edit
connect page so let's go to edit connect
page
so this is the code behind of the
ataconic page here in the edit connect
page in order to receive the parameter
value that it passed from the context
page we will need to have a property and
that property should correspond to that
parameter value in this case we're
receiving a contact ID so it's a
property and we only need to have a
Setter so this Setter will be triggered
when the information is passed over to
the added contact page right so then how
do we know that this is the property
that should be triggered right this is
the setter of the property distribute
trigger
on the class we can use a property and
we're going to say query property right
query property and the correct property
has has two parameters the first
parameter well let's talk about the
second parameter the second parameter is
actually the query ID and what is the
query ID it's basically this parameter
this the name of this parameter so in
here it's just called ID which is the
second one I'm tapping the second one
right and what is the first one the
first one is the name of the property
right so here we can say name of
contact ID right so name of the property
so basically this query let's stop this
right so basically this query property
is telling us that whenever we receive
the parameter value from the previous
page which is the context page we will
map that parameter value to this
property
okay and this property is right here
and then when that happens the setter
will be set and the value of that
property is within the value right
within the value uh you know in the
center we can call Value is within here
so now we actually have the the value of
the contact ID right inside the center
what should we do here
we need to call the contact Repository
right dot get contact by ID which we
just created right and here we have the
value that we need to pass in and of
course we can use
anti-parse
parse that into an integer uh if the
value is inappropriate that means we
need to throw exception we should let
that exception draw because that's a
coding error
right so we get the contact and then we
can store that contact in in a private
variable here and this private variable
we can Define it inside a co-behind
class and it's going to be of of course
a contact
and contact
uh that's it so here which contact class
are we are we referring to we can use
the same remember we are using the same
approach that we'll use last time so we
need to specify that we are referring to
our own contact class that we Define in
the models namespace in dot contact
and in the setter we basically set
the contact so now we have the contact
in order to prove that we actually
received contact let's go to the front
end of the ad iconic page and we see a
label
so let's give this enable label a name
right and so let's call it lbl
interesting name and then once we
receive the contact
we're going to assign that contact
right to
the label so that we can actually see it
and let's run the application
and let's see whether we can see the
contact name or not okay so let's click
on Tom Hanks
if for whatever reason we're seeing John
Doe and that's pretty weird I don't know
what's happening
so let's actually debug let's go to the
contact
first let's go to the contacts page
right and let's see whether the selected
item is actually correct let's actually
go back
and then I'm clicking on Tom Hanks
so the selected item
let's check what it is it's id0 of
course it's ID 0 because we didn't
actually provide ID Let's uh that's my
fault let's go back to contact
repository I didn't provide ID so
everything is zero so that's why it's
John though
because strando is the first item so
let's
um give the ID over here provide the ID
for each one of those item of course we
need to change them to one two three
four
and let's run the application again okay
let's try
myself
let's remove the breakpoint I think it's
gonna work
okay so I can see my name
go back Tom Hanks
um I thought I removed the breakpoint
but anyways
I've tap Tom Hanks so that's correct
let's try one more which is John Doe so
I have John Doe so everything looks
correct so in this lesson first we
learned about creating a stacking
repository this is mainly for teaching
purpose creating a static repository for
you is mainly for let's say you're
creating a mock-up right or uh you're
faking the repository so this static
repository will provide you with a
convenient way a quick way to mock the
data right and the later you can use
cling architecture the plugin based
clean architecture to plug in a
different Repository
okay so or you can use the static
repository to provide you of the fake
data for testing purpose let's say
you're in the QA team and then you want
to use a different data than the real
data then you can create a simple static
repository
to provide the data but anyhow I don't
prefer the static repository like I said
the static repository is mainly for
teaching so that we can quickly have
data
and we can uh still use the concept of
repository to encapsulate all of the
data operations within a central place
so that we don't have all of the data
operations scattered everywhere in our
application right I wanted it to be
encapsulated in a central place so we
learned about this concept we created
this static repository and then we learn
about passing information from one place
to another right one page to another
here we're passing through the query
parameter right and then this is the
value
and then inside the place where we
receive
the information right we use we first
create a write only right a right only
or set only property to receive that and
of course the the type of that should be
the type of
the parameter that is passed in from the
other page
and then over here we use a attribute
okay and this is the query property
attribute the first parameter is the
name of the property and the second one
is the name of the parameter right the
query string parameter
right and then you're going to receive
this
and that's everything I want to cover in
this video I'll see you in the next one
in the next a couple of videos we are
going to work on the edit contact page
and for that we need to familiarize
ourselves with stack layout
right currently if we go to the added
contact page we can see that there's the
vertical stack layout
actually there's a stack layout and the
orientation can be either vertical or
horizontal in Dynamite there's actually
for convenience purpose there's a
vertical stack layout
and a horizontal stack layout the
default orientation of a stack layout is
a vertical stack layout okay so if we do
it this way then it would be the same as
uh the vertical stack layout before we
change it right so if we let it run and
then we use hot reload to see what's
happening when we make changes then we
can see that they are the same okay the
application is running let's click on
one of the contact to go to the added
connect page right right now we have the
stack layout and it looks exactly the
same as the vertical stack layout right
because the default orientation is
vertical
okay let's learn about several things
about a stack layout first we have this
orientation which I mentioned so let's
actually put it on the left side and
then over application on the right hand
side so I'm going to put it over here
and then I'm going to drag this over
to here
and then let me minimize solution
Explorer so let me actually uh comment
out
look actually let's comment out the
whole thing okay to make it clearer
coming out the whole thing and then
let's go to the code behind
and let's comment out
uh this
and we don't have the cancel button so
let's come and not this
all right so let's just focus on how
stack layout works for now okay so let's
add a empty stack layout right so what
we need to know is first of all we need
to know some important properties of
Stack layout so let's put something
put box view right box view is basically
a view that looks like a box
so it's very good for placeholders and
it's very good for us to understand how
layout works we can specify the color of
a box view so that we can see the size
of the size and position of the Box view
right so if we just do it this way you
can see that there's nothing on it right
that's because we didn't specify the
size so let's specify the size and we
can use box view to understand how the
fuse in stack layout position how the
size and position worked I'm going to
add another one and we're gonna make
this one let's say it's going to be blue
right and another one maybe red
and another one maybe
yellow
right so if I save it you can see there
are different things so this tells us
that in the stack layout each one of the
child views are stacked together right
up and down because the orientation is
vertical right because the default
orientation is vertical
so each one of the child views are
stacked together right so agua is the
top one at the blue red and yellow so
you can see agua blue red yellow so if
we change the stack layout to horizontal
stack layout and then if I save it now
we see nothing why is that to answer
that question let's change the height
request to West request and then click
on the save button you can see that
everything is showing up and agua is on
the left obviously everything's stacked
together again but it's stacked from
left to the right right the vertical
layout stack views top to bottom and
horizontal stack layout stack views from
left to right
right and there's an important property
that we need to understand which is the
spacing right now you can see that each
one of the Box views are connected
together right so if we specify a
spacing here then you can see that
there's a space in between right so if
we change this back to vertical
then of course we have to change this to
height then you can also see the gaps
another thing that is very important is
for a vertical layout
a control like a box view button for
example by default it fills the entire
screen from left to right right and if
it's a horizontal stack layout by
default the Box view or buttons those
controls or views will fill the screen
from top to bottom right that's the
default Behavior but you can modify that
by specifying the with request so let's
say the width is 100. right so if I do
that notice that the agua box view is
changed
right and then this is only 100 from
left to right right that's the width
right so if I specify all of them all
right they look like that then the
question comes like how do we configure
the position of the Box view it's always
in the middle if there is horizontal
options right and by default the
horizontal option for a box viewer or a
button
um is Center but we specify start
then now you can see the Box view move
to the left
and we specify this
as a center and then
specify this as right sorry and
then you can see that Center is Center
start is Left End Is Right
right and deep default the yellow one
stays as default default is also Center
so for a vertical stack layout you
cannot position child views vertically
because they just stack on top of each
other well there's nothing to control
okay but you can configure the height
whereas for a vertical stack layout you
are able to configure the horizontal
positionings right and you have three
options Start Center and end
now when it comes to a horizontal stack
layout so let's comment out this
copy make a copy and then come down this
and then let's change this vertical
stack layout to hurry horizontal stack
layout of course now the Western height
kind of flips so we're going to change
this to 100
and with 250 otherwise it will look very
very weird because we don't have enough
space from left to right now you can see
that everything is in the middle the
horizontal options is not going to work
because for a horizontal stack layout we
can only control
the positioning of the child views on
the vertical level right on opposite
level so
what we can do is we can specify the
vertical options
for vertical options then we can specify
start
Center
and end so when we do that you can see
the start goes to the top right
because that's the agua and then blue is
in the center
and red is at the bottom
by default we don't specify anything a
state at the center right so now you can
see that for a horizontal layout you can
specify the position
vertically whereas for a vertical layout
you can specify the position
horizontally right using the horizontal
options whereas when it's a horizontal
layout you can use it vertical options
right so that's the takeaway and other
than that the spacing is very very
important of course again for vertical
stack layout you use the height request
to specify the size and then you use the
width request to specify the size for a
horizontal stack layout
now let's comment out the horizontal
stack layout and then we go back and use
the vertical stack layout well let's add
a label actually because label behaves
differently
uh from box view or a button so we're
going to say text test label
now
you can see that it appears
at this position so what is this
position this is horizontal position and
that's the start horizontal position
right so if we were to say horizontal
options start
and it's not going to change anything
right so let's also add a background
color
to say this is let's say gray
and now now you can see that the label
it's not like if we don't specify the
West request of the Box view the whole
thing is going to fill
the entire screen right on The Wiz
whereas for a label it does not
fill the entire width but we can use the
horizontal options to say fill
and when we do that you can see that the
entire width is occupied by the label
right because the background actually
tells us how big it is
and again we can use the horizontal
options to specify where the text is
positioned now you can see that
they are positioned differently
according to start Center and end right
so left middle and right another thing
you also want to understand is that
layout not only a stack layout all of
the layout can be nested right so for
example if we put another horizontal
stack layout inside the vertical select
layout so this is going to appear at the
bottom because it's the stack layout
right it's a vertical stack layout uh
and then we are going to put a label and
we're going to say
text equals name
right
and then we are going to say entry so
this entry is basically an input field
right entry over here
and now if I save it what does it look
like well you can see that this there's
entry field here you can see the the
keyboard is showing up
so this is a entry but you can actually
notice that there is a kind of a
misalignment remember that for
horizontal stack layout we can actually
use vertical options to specify the
alignment vertically right so let's
actually use vertical options here let's
say Center
right so that we can align them together
vertical options in the center so I'm
going to save now you can see that they
are aligned together beautifully right
so let me remove these squares and if we
even put words here you can see that
words is aligned with the label name
so everything looks perfect
and then of course if you want to add a
spacing between the label and the entry
view that you can use spacing over here
and let's say we put five there then
added a space here nicely right a gap
okay that's everything we want to
mention about stack layouts right
whether it's a vertical or horizontal
let's go ahead and actually work on this
this page
but remember that we only have two views
two meaningful views right a name and
email maybe let's add a phone number
right
and perhaps also a address
let's actually uh stop this
so we have a few other views and then we
can come over here to our contact page
and let's delete these
experimental layout here and let us add
the actual fuse so here I want to use a
horizontal stack layout to add the child
views right so we are going to have a
label just like what we did just now and
then this is going to be
um the name of the person
right and then we are going to have a
entry field for it for now there's no
data binding yet and of course we're
going to add vertical options Center and
then another vertical options Center
over here now we're going to copy this
and we're gonna repeat this a few times
all right because the first one is for
name the second one let's for email
second one the third one is for phone
number and maybe the last one is the
address okay now you can see we have our
name email phone number and address
right uh things are not actually aligned
properly so for vertical layout we want
to add a margin and we are going to say
10 0 0 0
then when we do that you can see that
the left changed so this is the margin
left
this is the margin top so let's say I'm
going to put 10 on the top as well
then you can see that it actually moved
down a little bit right so maybe uh the
margin 10 is not enough so let's specify
20.
right so that's better and then you can
see that uh the entry fields are not
aligned to the left so then how do we
fix that problem we can specify the wish
request for each one of the labels
all right let's say each one of them is
80 and then you can see that they are
aligned together but it seems that 80 is
too much so maybe uh let's say 60. now
that looks much better but if you want
to make a little bit better we can add a
frame
around the horizontal layout
okay so when we do that you can see that
name field becomes like this so why this
side the right hand side is sticking to
the Border that's because we didn't add
a margin here so uh we so this is
remember this is left and this is top
and this is right so we need to add the
same margin as the the left margin so
the right margin now becomes 20 and now
you can see that the frame basically
provides a border and it has a radius so
that looks pretty good but then it's too
big right it's too big so but we can
specify the padding all right the
padding is the inner side right margin
is the the outside and the padding is
inside if we specify zero to all of them
then it becomes like this it doesn't
looks really good so let's specify the
left hand side to be 10 and the the
right hand side to be 10 as well then
now it looks pretty good so maybe we can
add
top padding to be two and bottom to be
two and make it look a little bit better
right so now we can put frame on each
one of those horizontal layout
and now we have all of the views
beautifully displayed on the screen
perhaps I want to see a bigger gap on
the top so maybe uh 20s the top margin
so now everything looks much better so
that's what I want to cover for this
video and I'll see you in the next one
in this video we are going to continue
working on the edit connect page
okay so we had this these fields
displayed but one of the things that the
added contact page needs to do is to
display the contact information so we're
going to work on that first in this
video let's review we added the phone
and address views in the connect class
so now we go to the contact repository
maybe we should you know initialize them
maybe we don't have to right we don't
have to initialize them
so let's review that we do have this get
contact by ID method already
so this will help us to pull the
information
right and then let's go to the edit
contact page
and let's review that we already have
this uh parameter that is passed in
right and this property receive the ID
parameter from the URL and that retrieve
uh the contact object from our
Repository
and here we're supposed to assign the
information of the contact to our views
right here we have this these entries
later we're going to use data binding
but for now we're just going to use name
right we're using the event-driven
approach first and then followed by mvpm
so now we're going to use names to
reference so here this is this is entry
name and this one would be entry email
phone number
last but not least address okay so let's
go to the code behind
and let's assign those values over here
so Ng
name
Dot text equal
to well first of all this get contact by
ID matter May return nothing right if
the ID is incorrect that shouldn't
happen
but just to be safe we are going to say
if
contact is not now then we are going to
assign values to these views right so
this is name
and then we have entry dot address TX
text equals contact dot address email
all right so we have all four views in
here while we are here we're gonna put
this cancel button back
okay so let's go to the front end also
put our cancel button at the bottom
okay and let's delete the original stack
layout
let's put it over here at the bottom and
let's run the application to see whether
we can see the information of the
contact
all right okay it's running so let's go
to one of the contact now you can see
it's pulling the information in
we can see the name we can see the email
we don't have the phone number and we
don't have the address
click on the cancel button to make sure
that we can go back to our contacts page
all right let's go to another one make
sure it's polling the correct
information all the time
right all right it's doing pretty good
and we're going to try all of our
contacts
and this time it's Jane Doe so that's
pretty good so that's pretty good now we
should work on our updates for that
let's go to our repository first and
let's create a update method
again it's going to be a static method
and it's going to be a void function
and I'm going to call it optic contact
and first of all we're going to have the
ID to specify which contact we want to
update and then we're going to pass in
the the information that contains
the information that needs to be used to
update existing records right
so first of all we will need to make
sure that the ID that is passed in is
the same as the IDS in the contact
object right so if they're not the same
I'm just I'm just going to return
right and at this point they're the same
so because we're using a memory database
so we may encounter a problem here but
we will try to fix that problem when we
encounter that for now let's just code
normally right so what are we going to
do we are going to
um use the get config by ID right first
of all we're going to
get our Target contact to be updated
right so contact to
update equals
get
contact by ID and we just provide the ID
here and
we need to make sure that contact is
in the data store right so if it's not
now then we start updating eventually
when we use a database for example we're
not going to do this but for now we will
need to update a few manually of course
we're not going to update the ID but we
are going to update all of the other
views
so we have email
name and phone number if you want to use
automaper for example you can use that
but I think we don't have a lot of views
so I'm just manually populating them
again if you're interested you can check
out Auto mapper
right but I'm not going to use Auto
mapper in this course
so now we have the update contact method
right and let's go back to our front end
and we need to add a button and that
button is going to be the contact button
right do we have a spacing here
we do have a 10 spacing so that's pretty
good we don't have to adjust positioning
so this is going to be called BTN update
and of course
the text is going to be update
and we're going to generate a new event
handler here by doing this
right and let's just click right click
on it and then go to view then we can
see we have our new method here
so this is the event handler and here we
can use the category repository to do
the update right we have the update
method already remember we are not using
data binding so we will need to get
information from each one of these
fields right so what should we do we can
say contact remember we have a contact
already right defined over here and it's
populated with the contact ID method the
setter the contact ID property right
with the setter here
so we can say that contact dot name
equals entry name.txt contact Dot
address equals entry
address dot text so one of the reasons
to use mvvm is to eliminate the process
of autumn manually populating the fuse
right that's one of the reasons imagine
you have a lot of fields and you have to
do this many many times that's that's
definitely a pain
okay so I have all of the views
populated now I can say contact
dot contact ID
right and then here I'm just passing in
the contact object
okay so after I update the contact what
do I do of course I'm going to just
navigate back to the previous page which
is the contacts page so that's the same
effect of clicking on the cancel button
okay
so let's give it a try and see whether
it works or not
all right so let's go to any of the
contact
and let's for example add a phone number
is putting a random number here
and then I'm going to click on the
update button but before I do that let's
go to the configure repository and then
let's set a breakpoint here
right
I'm expecting a problem
but let's see whether we have that
problem or not
okay so I have the counter id4 which is
correct right and then I have
the phone number in here
but let's take a look at this contact
object and let's find the last one which
is
number four
right and you can see that there is
already a full number you don't even
need to update why is that like I
mentioned just now this is a in-memory
data store and when we call the get
contact by ID we're returning the object
inside this list so basically this
reference is returned back
so therefore when we are
um in the added contact page when we
when we handle the update event we
already updated that object in the list
directly then we don't even need to do
the update here because it's already
updated so that is incorrect because in
the actual data store we don't return a
reference of the object in the in the
server right so so for example if
there's a SQL Server there is an
instance of the server that's running
that's true but we don't return that we
return a copy of that value right so
therefore we will have to stop debugging
and we have to fix the problem so how do
we fix that problem we have to return a
copy here so this is the contact that we
found right and uh we're gonna say if
contact
is not now
then we're gonna make a copy right we're
gonna make a copy of the contact
if the contact is now
and then of course we're just returning
now here
okay and also most importantly the
contact ID has to be populated as well
okay so we fixed this problem here but
remember that we actually use the get
contact ID get contact by ID method down
in here and then we updating
this contact to update
but however
because we created a copy of the contact
so we cannot use the get contact by ID
anymore because this is a copy we Our
intention is to actually update
the object in that list right in which
list in this list so what we can do is
we can actually just copy this
right we use Lambda expression to
actually find
the uh the contact to update so we
change this variable to contact to
update and change this variable to
contact to update and then we close our
if statement and then we put our uh
logic inside
this particular if statement
okay
so you can see that we use we directly
looks for the contact object whose ID is
the same as the ID that is passed in and
then we if we can find the contact to
update object then we update it so this
time it should fix our problem and then
let's run the application again
okay let's choose one of them for
example if I choose myself and then
let's actually make a change in the
email as well so I'm gonna put a dot
between Frank and you so instead of
frankly it becomes frank.lu and then I'm
just going to put a a random phone
number here
if I click on the update button it's
going to take me to the contact list
right let's uh set up breakpoints do
setup breakpoint and make sure that
everything is updated properly right so
let's go over here we have the contact
ID that is passed in and we are able to
find the contact to update and then we
are updating them updating the the
information so let's actually look into
our list and let's see that you see that
email is updated and the phone number is
populated okay so let's continue and
remember that we provided we we changed
our email address we added a dot in here
so let's continue in and watch
right now you can see that this frankly
you at email address did not change
right but watch carefully if I click on
this contact list item again
going back
over here you can see that the dot is
here right the dot is here click on the
cancel button go back dot is gone so
that's a problem and we are going to
work on fixing that problem in the next
video
in the previous video we're having
problems of updating the contacts page
so let's go to contacts page and see
what's happening so we have this
Constructor here where we actually use
the iconic repository in the Constructor
and we get the contacts and we assign
the contacts to the item source so you
may be thinking that this is the reason
because the contacts page once it's
activated once it's created it lives
there in the memory and when we are back
like when we never get back from the
added contact page to the contacts page
uh this will not be executed so if we
can find a place to activate uh to call
those two lines of code again we might
be able to solve this problem so let's
actually do that okay so I'm cutting
those two lines and we're trying to
override one of the event in the event
cycle which is uh on appearing okay so
this online appearing is going to be
called every time the page regains the
focus for example if another page is on
top and then when we navigate back to
this page then the unappearing will be
called of course when the page is just
created and the first time it appears
the element appearing is going to be
called it seems to be the perfect place
to
um to call these two lines of code and
let's actually try that okay let's run
the application
yeah okay I'm going to go to Tom Hanks
and
I'm going to make a change
right had a thought again and then I
don't know his phone number I'm just
going to use Toronto's phone number for
example
random phone number uh clicking on the
update button I'm gonna remove this
breakpoint continue
and you can see we're still having the
same problem
right still having the same problem
if we click on it again you can see it
is actually already updated Tom dot X
right and we have the phone number but
going back
it's not showing so what is actually
happening
what is actually happening you may be
thinking oh maybe the unappearing is not
being called when we go back let's set a
breakpoint and see uh what's actually
happening there
so I'm appearing I'm going to set a
breakpoint here right so let's click on
this Tom Hanks go to Tom Hanks and then
come back
whether we click on cancel or update
it's going to navigate back you can see
that is actually being called right it's
being called and if we look at the
contacts
I think that's number three right you
can see that it's actually have the
correct data with the phone number but
the problem is with this line so it's it
looks like this line is not working
and then that's that's true it's not
actually not working
so let's go do the uh diagram let's draw
something so that hopefully I can make
you understand what is actually
happening so for example we have a page
here so this is a page
and then this page actually displays
some data right so let's make it
um vertical so it looks like a cell
phone right and then we have some data
that is loaded in the in the memory so
I'm using a circle to represent that a
data is loaded in the memory
right but remember that we have a a view
a view in here in this case we have a
list View and when the list view is
populated with the data the list view
stores a copy of that data in a
different format of course uh
in in the memory
we have another copy of that data which
is in the in the contact Repository
these two copies are not the same copy
so in dynamoi if you don't notify the
list view or any of you there's a change
in the data the data in the list View
or any other views will not actually
update
right you have to actually tell it to
notify the view that there is a change
in the data and then the view will do
the update so that's more or less like a
unique thing that you have to do in
Dynamite if you came from a web
application background you may be
thinking that's pretty weird but this is
this is what's happening in Maui you
have to notify it and the way to notify
it is to use
observable data so it's like observe
pattern where you have the data here and
then you have the subscribers so you
have subscriber one subscriber two you
know you have different number of
subscribers let's say we only have two
and then the subscriber is actually
subscribing to the observable data and
when the observable data changes it's
going to actually send a notification
and because both subscriber one and
subscriber 2 subscribe to the observable
data then it actually receives that
notification and then the subscriber can
do whatever it wants right so in
Dynamite this is already built in
okay in the in the views
so in our case we have the list view in
here and this list view is actually uh
when you bind the data to the list view
the list view tries to subscribe
but because you can see that we are not
using observable data so this is just a
list list of contacts right it's a
regular list
so that's why it's not actually working
because a regular list cannot send
notification to the.net Molly views
right in this case is list view so how
do we solve this problem
let's go back to our code
and then in here let's remove the
breakpoint
instead of just call the repository get
contacts we can use
observable collection
right so a new observable collection
you're gonna do control dot to import
namespace it's from
system.collections.optic model
so when we do that and we can provide
the type of the element and then in here
we can call
the repository to provide the data and
of course here this is going to be
a observable so we can use VAR
and now let's rebuild the application
and redeploy to our emulator
our application is running let's click
on one of the contact
and let's make the same change I'm going
to add actually I'm going to add a dash
here
and then whatever the phone number is
doesn't matter we're going to work on
the validation later so clicking on
update go back over here you can see
that Tom Dash Hanks gmail.com is being
displayed so that solves our problem
right because we are using observable
collection so when the observable
collection changes it actually notify
the list view so the list view then is
able to update itself with the new data
otherwise just keep the data in the
memory without updating which actually
saves the resources right
so that's what I want to cover in this
video and I'll see you in the next one
in the previous videos we have added
these fuse in the added connect page in
this video we are going to work on
validations
right for example the name should be
required email address should be a valid
email address to do that we are going to
go to the solution and then we click on
manage new get package
let's search community
toolkit
and when we do that we can see we have
this community toolkit dot Maui
and let's just select our project
and click on install
and I accept
so the toolkit is installed as a nuget
package right but then here it's
reminding us that we need to add this
line to our
Maui program.cs so let's go over here
and then let's add this line here and
then this actually resolved the problem
we have this using Community toolkit dot
Mali this is automatically added for us
so we just added this line which is
indicated in the redmi file so we
initialized our toolkit in there right
so this is for initializing the toolkit
let's close the Remy file coming back to
the added conic page so how do we use
the toolkit in the toolkit they're
different of course they're different
things the ones that we are interested
in are the validation behaviors
so for example
the name should be a required field
right meaning that it cannot be empty so
for that we can come over here under the
entry like within the entry we can say
entry dot behaviors
right
so this is this is part of the community
toolkit that we just installed
and then we can then use toolkit this
namespace does not exist right so we can
create that namespace here just like we
created this extension name space so we
need to do a XM XML namespace colon
toolkit you don't have the color toolkit
you can call it whatever you want but
here we need to refer to the toolkit
right the Maui took it that we just
added
and then here we can use toolkit colon
and you can see there's different
behaviors right there's even the
animation Behavior you can use for
animation but today we're going to cover
some of the validation behaviors like
first of all
four required field we can use the text
Behavior which is at the bottom right
text Behavior
and then you can close it don't have to
close it this like this we can close it
just like this
there are several properties in here to
make this text validation Behavior work
like a required field validation
Behavior we can just set the minimum
lens to be one right so at least there
has to be one character
right
another important property here is the
flex so this configures the behavior of
the text validation so do we validate on
attaching do we validate on focusing of
the entry field or do we validate on
value change I would suggest to validate
on a combination of both attaching right
so you can do a comma and then validate
on value change
so this guarantees that in any scenario
it's going to work for example let's say
this is a add contact page
so when you come to the ad connect page
all of the views are empty so you're
looking at the name field and if you
don't even touch it if you only specify
the validate on value change flag here
then when you click on the add button or
submit button it's not even going to
trigger the validation because you
didn't even change anything you didn't
even touch the field so the field is not
dirty it's not going to actually trigger
the validation at all that's why we also
need the validate on attaching that
means that when the validation behavior
is is attached to the entry field it
does the validation already right which
it will see that the field is empty and
then it will know that it's invalid
so we need a combination of this
right and then in order to reference
the validation field we need to give it
a name
so we can call it name validator
another important property I want to
mention but I'm not going to use today
is the regular expression pattern
property right so you can use this to
limit the format of the text in the
entry field so let's delete this
okay
so we're saying that name is a required
field right so so then how do we spit
out the error message so for that we can
go to the code behind
let's go to the code behind and just
before everything in the update clicked
event handler we can then say if if name
validator
is valid there is it is valid or is not
valid so if it's not valid then we're
gonna just return right but before we
return we can split up the error message
by saying display alert
and then the title is error the message
is
name is required
right and then you say okay so this will
help us to validate the name so let's
give it a try
okay the application is running and
let's go to one of the contact and of
course you know we only apply the
validator on the name field and there is
a value in here so it definitely is
valid so let's actually give it a try
click on update nothing's happening it's
valid so let's go back
and then let's try to delete this field
delete the name fill
and click on the update
now the area is showing
it's complaining that name is required
so now let's go back and let's put some
name over here let's just say whatever
name
and then click on the update button
again
now it's updated we can see the updated
name over here and then let's go back
and fix the name
okay that's a simple validation
so let's add another one
which is for email validation
so let's go to email
so when we look at the email address of
course we may think we need multiple
validation behaviors because the email
address may be required right for a
contact application maybe email address
is not actually required but for
demonstration purpose I want to make it
a little bit complex than the name right
let's say that email address is required
and of course email address format has
to be correct email address format right
so for that we actually have a thing in
the toolkit that is called
multi-validation Behavior so let's use
that
right because that one
um within the multi-validation behavior
you can combine different
validation behaviors
so in here again we're going to say
entry dot behaviors
right and then within that we're gonna
have toolkit and then we're gonna have a
multi-validation behavior okay
and
of course we are going to give it a name
we need to
reference that I'm going to call it
email validator and the flags will be
the same so let's copy these two and
then within the multi-validation
behavior we can have multiple validation
behaviors so the first one would be the
text validation
so let's copy the previous tax
validation Behavior over
here and then let's remove the name
because we don't need a name for this
right so this validation Behavior
provides us the required field
validation secondly we will need the
email validation behavior and our same
Flags
inside multi-validation Behavior there's
a way to provide error messages
so to do that we're going to say toolkit
dot multi-validation Behavior dot error
message right and then here uh in the
text validation Behavior we can just say
email is required
right and then let's copy this over to
the email Edition
and the message would be different
email format is invalid
and now we're ready to go back to our
code behind to trigger the validation
for the multi-validation behavior and
for that we are just going to use the
same way I'm going to say email
validator if it's invalid
then of course going to return first and
then before that
we are going to Loop through the error
messages
off the Modi validation Behavior
so for each error in email
validator
Dot errors you see it's a list of
objects but it's actually a list of
string
so for that we can just display the
alert
and we can just play multiple alert or
you can bind them together in a string
builder for example and just display
everything in one display alert in one
alert
but to simplify this I'm just going to
show all of them one by one so error
and then we can say to string so this is
the message and then the cancel button
is okay all right so let's give it a try
okay let's go to one of them
so of course I have a valid email
address already so let's test this let's
delete the field and then click on the
update button
this is the email format is invalid
and then also says email is required
right so it spit out all of the error
messages that we are expecting
so let's say I'm going to put a invalid
email address a b c
so click on the update
now I see email format is invalid click
on OK
you can see that the required field
validation is not triggered anymore
so
I can just provide a email address click
on update button going back you can see
that my email address is changed
validation behavior is not triggered so
everything works correctly so this is
what I want to show in this video I'll
see you in the next one
so we have created the added connect
page we have done the view validations
so there's a lot of work if we are going
to create a add contact page
the two pages look very very similar
right the functionalities are different
one of um add a page is to update
contact the add page is to add a new
contact
so because of the similarities we need
to think about create a reusable control
so that we can share that control
between these two pages so today in this
video we are going to work on creating a
reusable control
okay let's go to the Views folder and
let's right click and create a new
folder and let's call it controls and to
create a reusable control we are going
to create a new item
and we're going to search content view
okay
and then we're going to select the demo
version
and we can call it just contact control
right within the contact control we can
see there are some placeholders and this
is content view this is not content page
anymore so what we can do is that we can
go to edit contact page and then we can
basically select everything and cut it
over
okay let's cut it over to the content
control here right replace this vertical
layout
and you can see that we only have one
problem which is this toolkit namespace
problem so for that we can just fix that
very easily and call it toolkit just
like before
referring to this toolkit now you can
see that we don't have any problems in
here now let's look at this contact
control
what do we have here we have these
fields the name email red phone and
address
and these fuse needs to be shared out
right currently it's within the entry
email
and entry name all of these entry views
okay so we will need to share that out
through a property so let's create the
first property which is going to be the
name
and
we're just going to call it name right
because this is a Content control name
reverse name of the contact of course
here we cannot use a regular empty
Getters and Setters so for getter we
will just return the entry name dot text
right and as you guessed the setter will
just set the entry name
dot text equals to the value right now
I'll do that the the rest and then I'll
come back okay so I've created all of
them I have email address and phone
number
for sharing properties values uh we're
good now we go back to the front end we
can see we have taken care of these
properties what about the buttons down
below
right we have update button we have a
cancel button I think we should change
the name from update to save right and
then here it's called save
just so that it can be reused in both ad
and edit page and here we are going to
create a new event handler and for this
one as well create a new event handler
going back to the code behind
and we have these two event handler here
we don't need to take care of the
routing right the navigation but we do
need to validate okay so let's go back
to the edit contact page
and let's think about how we can
implement the validation here you can
just cut this code
and go back to the connect control and
then we can do our validation inside
here but the problem is that display
alert is not available display alert is
only available in in the page right it's
basically a Content page so let's
actually actually let's go back to our
uh add a contact page if I do a control
Z to undo the change and then if I right
click if I actually hover my mouse over
it you can see it's the display alert is
from page right and our content page is
a page
but the content view is not a page so
display alert is not available here but
that's fine that's fine we are going to
delete it
or both of them
but here
we will need to
spit out the error so how do we speed up
error we need to create a event
uh it's like a delegate in C sharp so
here we can create an event uh it's
going to be an event handler and then
the the parameter is going to be a
string which will be the error message
itself
and then the event itself is going to be
called on error okay
so we can then scroll down to the bottom
and then here if we encounter a problem
right then we will need to speed up that
error message we're going to say on
error right and we need to use a
question mark so basically if the event
handler is registered right from outside
then we're going to invoke the event
otherwise we don't right that's the
purpose of this question mark here I'm
going to type Dot and then invoke right
and then who is the sender so we can
just pass the center from the event The
Click event and then what is the error
message
so that would be the same error message
that we had before I wish I didn't
delete them and just comment them out so
that I don't have to type this but its
name is required right and then I'm
going to copy this and put it over here
uh the only difference here is that the
error message is different so it's going
to be error.2 string
and that's it
right that's it
but how does the parent control knows
that the save button is actually clicked
on
for that we actually need to create
another event
and type is event handler this time we
can just use event arguments
and this is on Save
right and since we are here we're going
to also
um
react to the cancel button click right
so then here
when everything is validated then we can
tell our parent page whichever page that
uses this control that the user clicked
on the save button it's actually
validated already right so whenever this
event on Save is triggered
is revoked we have already validated
right so here we can just invoke and
then we use the sender and also the
event argument from the clicked event
okay and then of course on cancel
uh we can just say on cancel and then we
invoke that event with the sender and
the event argument that's basically it
that's our reusable contact control so
now now let's try to use it go back to
the added contact page and then let's
see how we can use the reusable control
first of all
to use this new control we need to
provide the namespace because if we just
type the control name right contact
control it's not defined here so let's
go to here and then
we're gonna say controls again whatever
name you choose I'm choosing controls
and then
it's under controls
so we can find it right here
then we can say controls providing the
namespace
well it's already showing up right all
of them already showing up there's only
one
uh and then we can give it a name
and we can call it contact control and
then we're going to register a unsafe
event handler here
and we're going to create a new one
actually
um we're not going to create a new one
we're going to create we're going to
reuse
one because there's already one so it's
this update right
and then here on cancel again we're
going to reuse this one
but on error we don't have it we can
create a new event handler
right and that's it
you can see it is very very simple on
the front end go back to the back end
uh it's even simpler because we are
reusing these event handlers this unsafe
we don't use it anymore we don't use it
we can delete it uh the only thing that
needs to be changed is here we don't
have the the entry views anymore so the
what we can do is we can say
contact control contract I use the wrong
names it should be contact
instead of contract right contact
control so go back here and we need to
fix this as well contact control on
error okay
so here we're going to say contact
control dot name
right and then this is going to be
contact control dot address and contact
control dot email last but not least
contact control.phone number okay and
then here the validations don't need to
be happening here anymore because this
event handler will only be invoked
or triggered when validation has
finished right has passed what we do
need to change is these assignments so I
can just delete all of them and then I'm
going to copy
from here
and paste it over here
okay
and then just fix the problems
okay so now on error what do we need to
do when we encounter an error this is a
string which contains the error message
so of course we just use the display
alert from the page class and then title
is going to be error as Euro message is
just the
message and then cancel is ok button
so that's it that's how we use our
reusable contact control let's let's
give it a test
okay you can see the applications
running let's click on any one of them
and now we see the add a contact page no
difference
let's try to see whether we can update
I put a dot there but let me actually
delete
the
add sign just try to trigger the
validation problem right so email format
is invalid so that's validation is
going on properly let's also
try to delete the whole thing
and then click on save this time it
tells us not only the format is invalid
but also it's required so let's put back
the email address so John dot doe
gmail.com and then click on the save
button now I have John Doe gmail.com
going back
phone number is
whatever
right address is one
let's say Toronto Street
click on save button
and everything is basically still
working right but this time we're using
our reusable contact control in the next
video we're gonna use the control the
contact control in the add contact page
and we're going to work on adding
contact
I'll see you in the next one
in this video we're going to work on the
add contact page
but first of all going to the add
contact page is triggered from the
contacts page right so this is the
contacts page I'm looking at right now
and it has a list View
and a list view is just a single view so
we really need to have a list view in a
layout so we have talked about
the stack layout before today instead of
using stack layout I would like to use
the grid so that we can learn more
things so a grade is basically like a
table it has columns and rows
right so if I put a grate here
so
if I don't specify columns or rows
then you can basically just put a list
view here right one view is going to
still work you're not actually using a
grade as a grade right
to use it properly we need to Define
like how many columns and how many rows
and how big each column or rows are
right for that we need two properties
one is called row definition so you can
see role definitions and for this
particular page we are going to have the
list view in the first row and then a
button which is the add button in the
second row so we have two rows
so here we basically in the row
definition we just specify the height
like x y z so in this case we have uh
three rows
and the first Row's height is X the
second Row's height is y and of course
the last Row's height is z but what
about you don't want to actually specify
a specific number
you just want to say the last row is for
example 50 and then the first row takes
the rest of the space then you can just
say start right star means it takes as
much as it can and then we can specify
the column definition
how many columns do I do we have and how
big is each column right so it's the
same format x y z each one of them has
to be a number you can see that is
complaining you cannot use x by Z
because it doesn't really know how big
what H1 column is so in this case we
actually only have one column
right and then in the list viewer in in
The Insider grade we need to specify
which row and column each view is within
so the list view is in row number one
and column number one so we can just say
Great Dot row number one this is the
index starting from zero so basically
when we refer to the first row we're
going to say zero right and then and
then of course the column is also zero
now when it comes to the second one
which is going to be a button and we'll
give it a name first
this is going to be a add button and the
text is add contact for example and we
are going to add a
collect event handler
since we're here already
okay but this button needs to be in the
second row and First Column so we're
going to say grade dot row
second second row is number one
and grade dot column
and it's going to be zero the first call
all right
let's run the application and see
whether we have a correct page we can't
see anything in the application but I
noticed that I made a mistake here it's
not this is not number of columns this
is how big the column is because we only
have one so we can use star because this
column should expand to as much as it
should right so now we can see all of
the data in the back end let's go to the
view code
we have this at event handler here we
want to navigate to
our ad contact page okay so let's
continue working on coding the added the
add contact page so let's go to add
contact page there's basically this
welcome page right so there's basically
nothing in it it does have a a cancel
button
so we don't need any of this because the
contact control already has a cancel
button and it has everything else that
we need so basically we can go to the
added contact page and we can just copy
this
and go back to add contact page and then
we just
replace
this
replace everything of course the
namespace also needs to be added
so we can go to the top
and then we can specify the controls
come from the controls which is right
here and now the problem is fixed so
um on Save needs to be recreated the
event handler
new Handler
on cancel
new Handler and on error
also needs to be create a new event
handler
that's it at the front end very simple
as the beauty of creating a reusable
control we don't do a lot of work
because all of the work already been
done right going back to the back end
save
so what should we do on unsafe we need
to call the repository to add the new
contact but do we already have a add
method here we don't so first of all we
need to create a add contact method okay
so here we create a static method and
then we're gonna it's gonna be void and
I'm gonna call it add contact
and of course uh the parameter is a
contact
and then we are going to first of all we
need to get a maximum ID right remember
this is a
memory so
in memory data store so we need to
manually get the the ID so we need to
get the contact ID the maximum contact
ID right and then we can say contact dot
contact ID so we assign the ID to it
so it's maximum ID plus one right and
after that we can just add this contact
into the contacts list okay so that's it
that's our method very simple method
without much validation you know if we
add a duplicate contact we can always
try to delete it which we're going to
work on later
so coming back to the add contact page
inside save event handler we can use the
contact Repository
and then we can call the add contact
of course here we need to create a new
contact
okay just like this and then we can
specify the name equals to contact
control
dot name right remember that we exposed
we expose all of the property out and
then Visual Studio is suggesting email
equals to email
I hope it actually suggests the next one
but it doesn't
it doesn't always help but it's
already helping a little bit
then we just specify address is address
and phone is phone and then we close
with a semicolon so that's our ad
contact remember here when it comes to
this method everything's already
validated right it's a valid contact
and then if there is an error then this
on error event handler will be triggered
and the only thing we need to do here is
just to display the error message
right so we can say this play alert
and the title is error
message is from the event argument and
the cancel button is okay
so this e is the error message that
comes from the parameter here which is
the event argument of that event handler
and then of course the shell um the on
cancel event handler just basically you
know go back
you can just uh shell.current Dot
go to async and where are we going we
are going back to the contact page we
can use dot dot but if not then we can
use
um
specify the root right and then we can
say name of
I think we already have a
yeah we already have a console
so in here we created a new event
handler
that's fine we can just copy this over
okay so when we go to the root we always
try to specify slash slash or if we
don't then we can use dot dot to
navigate back to the to the previous
page
right to the parent page so I think
that's everything let's give it a try
I know there's a problem here that after
this add contact we need to navigate
back to the contacts page so I just
duplicated this line here
okay now let's give it a try
okay so we have this list of contacts
and then we can click on any of them
going to the added contact page still
working
now let's test the add contact page so I
think we're having some problems here
with the layout
okay so let's try to fix the layout
problem first
because the hot reload actually
works for the front end so we don't have
to stop
so we can fix that very quickly go to
the contacts page here uh I think we
need to add some paddings for the great
because you can see the button is not
positioned properly
so let's add some
some padding
so let's add maybe five let's see how it
looks like now now looks much better you
can see that everything is positioned
correctly so clicking on on the add
contact button this should take us to
the ad contact page now you can see we
have all of this clicking on the save
button this should trigger the
validations and we should be able to see
all of the validation errors
so name is required
right so then I'm going to add I don't
know this person's name is Monday Smith
and then clicking on the save button
again to trigger the email validation
email is required and format has to be
correct
so let's call it just submiss gmail.com
in the spirit of testing
and providing a wrong format so then
it's actually validating it
um
and then phone number is optional
address is optional so I'm just going to
provide something
clicking on the save button going back
we can see Monday Smith
okay so it's working beautifully so
again let's take a look what we have
done
go to the add contact page you can see
that we basically did almost nothing
right just reusing the functionality
that we already created so this is the
beauty of using a reusable control okay
so that's everything I want to cover in
this video I'll see you in the next one
foreign
text application the next step is to be
able to delete a contact within a
contact list right so let's go to the
contacts page
and we can see that we have this list
View and then within the list view we
have this item template which is
basically a text so we can kind of add a
button there
by using view cell instead of text cell
because within the view cell you can
place a whatever view you want even a
stack layout right we can use a
horizontal stack layer and put a button
there but list view has a context action
and within context actions you can put
one or more menu items so instead of
using buttons I think we should learn
about using context actions so let's do
that first of all so we have this text
cell right so
within this element let's actually
format it a little bit better
scroll up a little
and then minimize solution Explorer so
here
within the text
so we can say text cell Dot dot context
actions right and then within this
context action
then we can add menu items
and for example we can have a delete
which is exactly the functionality we
want right we can have multiple ones
let's say
text maybe let's say instead of using
tap uh to edit or view the contact item
we can have the edit button right here
for example well I'm just showing
there's possibility of having multiple
menu items and then if we run our
application let's see how it looks like
like how the context manual looks like
okay you can see our application is
running if we want to trigger the
context menu what we need to do is long
press long price and you can see the
context menu is showing up on the top on
different devices it may look different
um Windows the context menu is actually
showing right here just like a regular
Windows application right
um Android is showing on the top for
other application contents application
we are going to delete this added we're
only going to have this uh Delete right
here and you can see immediately the
added contacts menu is gone and delete
is here so when I click on it nothing is
happening that's because nothing is
implemented for delete before I go ahead
and Implement delete functionality
there's one more thing I want to point
out which is for the menu items there is
a property here and it says is
destructive so if we set this to True uh
you analysis actually see on Android
nothing is special so delete is delete
but
um
other devices like iOS I believe uh thus
delete many item will be displayed in
red right because this is destructive
here nothing is happening in Android
okay to react to this delete event what
we can do is we can add a event handler
to The Click event right so clicked
event and then we can just say new event
handler okay
all right so then at the back end you
can see a new event is added but how do
we know which which contact triggered
the context menu so we will need to use
a data binding as we mentioned before
the data binding in list view is by
binding context so for each item see
here is item template so for each item
The Binding context is
the contact itself so go back to the
backend let's review that we have a list
of contact here right
it's observation list but it's still a
list
right so we have a list of contact and
each item within that list is a contact
object right so here The Binding context
for this
for the entire item template is the
contact object itself so therefore what
we can do here is to say command
parameter commit sorry not command but
command parameter and then we are going
to use binding again
but this time we're going to use a
little bit differently we're going to
say dot
what does that mean the start refers to
the object that is bound to this current
item
right so instead of going like drilling
down into which property we're binding
to we're actually just binding to the
entire object which is the contact
object right and after that we can go to
our backend go to our backend and go
here now we can retrieve the contact
object directly from here by saying VAR
menu item
right and sender so who sent it it's a
menu item right
we because we clicked on the menu item
menu item is the sender and then we can
cast
a menu item dot command parameter
to contact object all right so now we
have a connect object
and then we are going to run the delete
functionality so but we don't have a
delete functionality yet so let's go to
our
models and contact repository and then
let's add our delete functionality in
here
okay so it's going to be pretty simple
uh we are going to say delete contact
and then here instead of passing the
entire iconic object we don't actually
need it we can just pass the contact ID
of course in the data binding we don't
have to use
binding dot we can just say binding
contact ID right but I want to show you
there's actually this way of binding the
current object right so here we're
trying to get the the contact by ID
and to do that we can just use Lambda
expression just like before we can say
contact ID equals contact ID and if the
contact
is not now then we are going to actually
remove this
okay we're going to remove this contact
object okay so that's uh the
functionality in here
so we did that and then let's go back to
our code behind and let's look at this
menu item click so we have this contact
now we can use our contact repository
and then we can call the delete contact
method that we just added and no one can
say
contact.contact ID and that's good
enough right that's good enough but if
we run it guess what's going to happen
contact will be deleted from the connect
list however you won't see a change in
the list View why is that because
um because we didn't actually refresh
the list view remember the contact list
in memory and the contact list in the
list view are two different things
and we have to notify the list view that
we have a change that's why we need to
do something like uh let's go up here in
the unappearing uh we have this uh these
two lines of code here right which will
kind of force a refreshing so we will
need to extract this out to in a
different method in the private helper
method
and we're going to call it load contacts
okay
so here we're just uh going to paste
these two lines in here and then go up
go up over here
uh we're gonna call the contacts a load
contacts
and of course inside the delete
functionality here we're going to also
call the load context here I don't like
calling it menu item clicked right
because it's not actually clear what is
actually happening let's actually call
it uh Delete delete clicked
okay so let's go back and then here
let's change that to delete clicked
maybe we can just delete the whole thing
and then here we can select or delete
clicked
uh I don't know why it's complaining
uh it's saying that delete click that's
not found that's pretty weird so we have
this delete clicked right here I think
it's just um oh because we are still
running the application
okay so let's stop it and then that
should resolve the problem okay so let's
uh we completed our recording for delete
contact let's run the application again
to see whether it works
all right so let's try to delete let's
say the first one so long click and then
click on delete and then you can see
that it's gone right so delete
that's what I want to cover in this
video
in this video we're going to work on
search context functionality because we
already implemented a view contact add
contact delete contacts and update
contact so now we just need the final
functionality which is to search
contacts because we may have lots of
contacts and it would be nice to be able
to search and find the contacts that
we're looking for right so for that
let's go into the contacts page right so
contacts page right now you can see that
we have a grade and then inside the grid
we have a list View and a button right
so a search bar should be put on the top
right so we can have a search bar here
and in dynamoe there is actually a
search bar already you can actually you
can already see it right here right
so in order to display the search bar we
have to change our grade so that instead
of having two rows now we need three
rows so we can put like 50. right so the
first row is for the search bar which
the height of that is about 50. and then
the second one is going to be as big as
it can get to and then the last one is
where the add contact button is located
so that one also has 50. right so we can
do that and then we need to change
um actually let's copy these two
properties here or attributes and then
put it inside here on the search bar
that would be good and then we need to
change the row for the list View and as
well as the row for the button which is
number two
okay now we should be able to display
the search bar and we need to let the
user know that this is actually a search
bar for that the placeholder attribute
is is the best attribute to use and we
can say something like search contact
right so the user know that this bar is
for searching contacts and in order to
react to the search there are a couple
of events we can take advantage of one
of them is
text changed right so this event so
let's let's actually have this one as
well as uh there is a search button
pressed so there are two events that
it's uh that can be used
right I would prefer to use the text
changed because the text change the
event is triggered whenever you actually
type anything right so this is different
from a for example a web application
where you try to trigger a text change
so the text is only changed when the
cursor
leaves the the input box
right here while you're typing the event
is actually triggered uh whereas the
search button pressed usually it's going
to show for example magnify glass in the
search bar and then when you press on
that or tap on that magnify glass then
this event is triggered so I don't like
it because it's not very intuitive so
let's actually uh delete this one
okay and then let's go back to the front
end and also delete this one but if
that's your requirement that you have to
press on the the magnify glass then yeah
you can feel free to use that but for us
we're going to use the text changed
event and then uh in that exchange event
so let's go back to the code behind we
will have to use the context repository
right this is temporary repository we're
using to load in memory data right
so we can use contact repository but we
don't actually have a search
functionality yet
right we don't have that yet but we
don't have it but we can code it here so
uh what needs to be inside the search
contact functionality actually let's
call it call it search contact
so this has to be uh whatever that is
this the user typed in the search bar
for for that we can get it from the
sender because the sender is actually
the search bar so we can say search bar
sender so this is casting this the
sender to the search bar and then the
text is what the user entered
so this is good enough and this should
return us the the list of contacts right
so we will have the contacts here and
then look at the load contacts right so
we have this contacts here but then this
context is different so we will need to
use the observable collection and then
we can wrap around like this so then
this context is a observable contact
right and then you can just copy this
line and put it over here and that's it
that's uh that's it and the rest of the
work is just implement the search
context uh method or actually a function
okay so let's copy the search contacts
and go to the contact repository go down
to the bottom and then we're going to
create another public static
uh public static function which is going
to return a list of contacts and that
would be similar to this one right so
it's going to be list
of contact and then here we're going to
call it
search contacts
and this is basically filter text
you call it whatever and then here
inside the contacts
we can just basically say where
X name
start with
filter
text and then we can say string
comparison we already know you can
lowercase okay so we want to ignore case
I wanted to we we want it to be case
insensitive
right and this is going to return as a
ineurable and we can cast it into a list
like that so we can do two lists
contacts
so here we're only looking at the name
but we actually should enable the user
to search by anything right the name
phone number address or email address so
we uh we actually need to Let's actually
copy and paste this slide
and then we can test the other three
Fields here so what we need to say here
is that if the contacts
sorry not contact but contact if it's
not now
and also if
contacts dot count
is uh actually it if it's null
or
contacts.com
last or equal to zero
that means we didn't find anything so in
in this case we'll have to find
we'll have to look for the filter tax in
some other fields right so let's say the
second one we're looking at is email
right
and if otherwise if we did find
something from the first query then we
just return
right and we are going to do the same
thing over and over again for another
two times right so here we are going to
say this is uh a phone number maybe
and last but not least
we're looking at address so we can see
that if we ever run to this line then
the the result is not returned so
therefore we will have to at the end
return the contacts
just like this and this contacts at the
end can be a empty list another thing we
need to pay attention to is that one of
these ones can be null right name email
phone number or addresses can be known
so in order to solve that problem we
actually have to add some condition over
here otherwise it's going to throw like
object reference like null reference
problem
we can use
a condition over here
say is now or empty or y space
okay so the X
um
name here has to be not empty and it has
to start with the filter tax
okay and then we're going to apply the
same condition to the other ones
I'm going to put over here of course
this has to be changed to email
and this is phone number and this one is
address
okay
so the condition is it's not now or
empty
and it starts with the contacts the
filter text then that
satisfastic criteria
and we'll get our contact back the
correct context back uh here where we
have our search tax change the search
bar text changed
um and you can see that the problem is
gone and we should be able to just use
this so let's run our application and
see whether it works or not foreign
okay so now we can see our search
contacts bar is right here so let's type
in the first character J actually let's
put a breakpoint over here and just make
make sure that the event is actually
triggered while we're typing right so
I'm gonna use the uh the soft keyboard
like the virtual one so I'm putting J
here and you can see this is immediately
trigger right it doesn't actually
need the cursor to to to actually leave
but you may think that I press here so
the cursor actually left well it's
actually not the case so so actually
let's uh continue so I'm going to press
on F5 so let's continue right uh let's
actually delete this right basically
clear the the box and you can see it's
also triggered right away okay and then
now it's cleared so instead of using the
soft keyboard I'm just going to type the
letter J right inside like with my
keyboard so I tap J and now you can see
that the breakpoint triggered that's
just proves that the tax change event is
not triggered when the customer leaves
the search bar right so I'm I press on
F5 so continue right so I type in j a
now I can see Jane though so the search
actually works right and then I can type
in Jane tab on Jane though and go to see
the details of Jane Doe right go cancel
button takes us back to here
unfortunately uh the search bar didn't
actually clear and everything is um
is still showing right so for that
purpose what we can do is that only
appearing here we can do some house
cleaning here we can say that search bar
actually we didn't give it a name yet
did we go back to contact so let's stop
this
and go back to contacts we didn't give
it a name yet so we can say name he
codes just just call it search bar okay
so here we can say search bar dot text
equals string dot empty okay
so with this change let's give it a test
again
all right so now let's go to I should go
to myself
Frank
and then click on my contact
and click on cancel button now you can
see that the search bar is cleared okay
so that's the functionality I want to
cover today I'll see you in the next one
foreign